la statue de christophe colomb des
boulonnais le jour de la fête nationale
américaine un symbole très fort la scène
s'est déroulée samedi à baltimore où une
ville du nord-est des etats-unis après
une manifestation contre les inégalités
raciales
les protestataires considèrent la statue
de christophe colomb comme un symbole
lié à l'histoire coloniale et aux
discriminations avec quelques heures
plus tôt donald trump a prononcé un
discours à l'occasion de la fête
nationale et a salué la figure du
navigateur génois
nous ne laisserons personne démolir un
autre histoire at il déclaré et pour en
parler nous sommes avec jean pierre
guéno historien jean-pierre guéno merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors la statue de christophe colomb ce
n'est pas la première déboulonner il y
en a eu beaucoup depuis quelques
semaines comment analysez vous cette
colère des manifestants à l'encontre de
figures historiques
ils veulent davantage gommer l'histoire
ou s'inscrire dans l'histoire selon vous
il découvre l'eau chaude avec beaucoup
de retard et quand on veut déboulonner
des statuts mais on ne fait rien d'autre
que de chercher à gommer les jalons les
indices de l'histoire et c'est quelque
chose de très grave
christophe que l'on est comme la plupart
des têtes d affiche de notre histoire
l'histoire du monde
il ya une part de lumière et ya une part
d'ombré ni et ça ce serait donner une
vision manichéenne de l'histoire avec
les bons d'un côté les méchants de
l'autre
rappelons l'histoire de l'exclavage les
d'abord l'esclavagé malheureusement
vieux comme la présence humaine nous
avoir un bon abondamment pratiqué
l'esclavagé en france au moyen-âge avec
le servage du côté africain les premiers
esclavagistes ont été les rois noir qui
mettaient en esclavage leur propre
peuple
leur frère ou bien des tribus des tribus
rivales
donc tout ça est très complexe et en ce
qui concerne christophe colombien s'est
simultanément un formidable navigateur
un formidable explorateur un formidable
découvreurs
et il est vrai à une époque où c'était
dans l'air du temps à grant
esclavagistes qui n'hésitait pas à
exploiter les indiens d'amérique du sud
est il qu'il découvrait à couper les
mains des enfants ou kiki qui refusaient
la loi de l' esclavage
voilà donc je pense qu'il faut arrêter
cela de la même façon qu'ils aient ronda
vous évoquez le déboulonnage de la
statue le jour de la fête nationale
américaine
hier c'était la dépendance de l'algérie
et le président algérien n'a pas hésité
pour essayer d'arranger ses propres
problèmes politiques avec un peu oui
qu'il opprime et il faut rappeler que
l'algérie est un pays potentiellement
très prospère et il n'a pas hésité à
rappeler à la france qu'ils attendaient
de sa part une forme de repentance
alors tout ça vient d'un problème global
mais finalement lui oui finalement voilà
jean pierre guéno quand on s'en prend à
l'histoire de son pays qu'est ce que
cela révèle de nos sociétés occidentales
au fond cela révèle le fait que nous
n'avons pas purgé notre mémoire
et quand la mémoire des pas purgée quand
on ne verse pas les abcès
quand on est dans le déni et bien d'une
certaine façon l'histoire est voilée
comme une hélice et les voilées et les
faussetés il faut purger les abcès de la
mémoire pour retrouver confiance dans
l'histoire et là on parle de la mémoire
de la colonisation on en a fait des
tonnes sur la décolonisation mais
l'histoire de la colonisation est bien
antérieur et elle a été très longtemps
absente jusqu'à il ya une dizaine
d'années de nos livres d'histoire
en ce qui concerne l'algérie la
colonisation c'est 1830 1850
c'est oradour sur glane tous les quinze
jours avec deux grands maréchaux l
maréchal bugeaud et le maréchal de
saint-arnaud bon bah voilà
il serait temps de purger ces abcès
parce qu'une fois qu'on les a purgés
c'est un peu comme sur le divan du
psychanalyste et bien les choses vont
beaucoup mieux comment on fait
comment on fait pour pour purger ces
abcès justement on ne l'était pas on ne
les cache pas je vous rappelle qu'en
france la guerre d'algérie n'est
toujours pas eu de guerre c'est une
guerre de pacification
je vous rappelle que pendant cette
guerre la torture a été pratiquée dans
les deux camps avec les mêmes alibi
monstrueux donc ça c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas acceptable
donc tout ça doit passer par un travail
pédagogique
on a maintenant des outils merveilleux
on n'est pas obligé d'être que d'imposer
des plaques sous les plaques de rue il
ya des qr codes ya tout un tas de choses
qui permettent d'adapter les moyens de
communication modernes à la pédagogie
moderne
il faut sortir du déni il faut percer
les abcès de la mémoire pour retrouver
confiance dans l'histoire c'est faire la
différence entre l'histoire et la
mémoire au fond c'est ça qui me dit
les deux sont complémentaires il ya de
fausses querelles les historiens
conteste la mémoire parce que la mémoire
c'est celle des vivants c'est celle du
peuple c'est celle de nos parents et nos
grands parents et celle ci il faut la
purge est parce qu après l'histoire est
faussé si si la mémoire n'a pas pu se
faire entendre l'histoire est faussé ce
qui est formidable prenons le maréchal
de saint-arnaud qui était le grand
tortionnaires de la conquête de
l'algérie entre 1830 et 1150 cet homme
tué h 24 dieu merci il ya deux statues
lui dans le monde
une heure de str allie une en france et
grâce à ça eh bien on peut arriver à ne
pas oublier que cet homme était un
boucher s'il n'y avait pas de statut il
aurait définitivement disparu des écrans
radars alors pour revenir à ce qui s'est
passé à baltimore qui n'est pas
n'importe quelle ville on le disait elle
a été traversé par de violentes émeutes
il y a cinq ans après la mort de fredy
grèce était un afro américain de 25 ans
est ce qu'on est en train d'assister à
une dit
lyon irréversible de la société
américaine non je ne le pense pas du
tout je pense que c'est un c'est un
passage il ya beaucoup de minorités aux
etats unis c'est un c'est un faux
melting-pot ce melting-pot a effacé des
minorités antérieures comme celle des
dernières d'amérique du nord qui ont
quand même été les premiers à être à
être sacrifié il ya d'autres minorités
on dit toujours que les asiatiques se
sont mieux intégrés mais enfin il n'en
demeure pas moins qu'ils ont été
victimes eux aussi de natal de strates 6
mai 2 de discrimination dont je pense
que ce sont des passages avec des
défoulement hystérique provisoire il
faut que les gens acquièrent une
certaine maturité
vous savez aujourd'hui la discrimination
est essentielle qui est qu'elle est
aujourd'hui quand on colonise ont
colonisé des zones où des minorités je
pose toujours la question piège qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
la survivance de la colonisation qu'elle
est l'être humain toujours colonisés
toujours discriminés c'est tout
simplement la femme
quand vous regardez nous sommes en 2020
les différentiels de salaires à
responsabilités égales mais ça prouve
que dans ce domaine est quelque chose
qu'il va pas du tout voilà mr alors si
je regarde
regardons l'avenir essayons de bâtir
plutôt que de regarder dans le
rétroviseur de façon stérile et
rétrograde
merci beaucoup jean pierre guéno on
arrive au terme de notre journal merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes historien